are you looking to pick up the Legend of
Zelda Twilight Princess HD that packed
in wolf Lincoln me but looks pretty
slick even better it unlocks a brand new
dungeon in the game amazon france leaked
the name of the new dungeon which
translates to the cave of twilight so
you can imagine what sort of puzzles and
traps it could throw at you it should be
a fun place to explore alongside the
game's other dungeons like Snow Peak
ruins and city in the sky the cave of
Twilight isn't the only new addition to
Twilight Princess HD you can also use
amiibos like toon link and chic to
replenish links health and arrows the
game supports a hero mode and will place
inventory management on the gamepad
something we've all wanted since the wii
u was announced Twilight Princess HD hit
store shelves on march forth and it'll
be good excuse to take another journey
through Hyrule if nintendo announces
anything else about links adventure you
can bet your Giants wallet you'll hear
about it on gamespot